this is this is quite funny that I
stepping after the last sentence of
Rosie's presentation because I actually
represent the founder so my name is Maya
coinkle and I work for Arcadia funds I
would like to start with ranking or the
organizers particularly professor Simon
for inviting me and 2 i'm giving him the
opportunity to to give our perspective
limited that it is so i'm not going to
speak for a very long time so Arcadia is
a private london-based foundation which
offers grants to protect endangered
culture and nature around the globe
since its inception in 2001 Arcadia has
offered over 330 million dollars in
grants and it is a substantial amount we
think for a foundation with the staff of
four people but in reality it is only a
drop in the ocean of needs we are
therefore very acutely aware of the
necessity to thanks strategically and to
ensure that Arcadia supports initiatives
that can make the most significant and
lasting difference and because of that
i'm also very grateful to be in this
particular session because this means
that we are very acutely aware that to
make any difference at all we do have to
work together so in terms of the
projects and how we choose them the
situation of every project it is of
course different but overall there are
three wide guiding principles for Acadia
funding the first is that we only
support projects which work in
partnership with countries and
communities who are the custodians of
the heritage for majority of the
projects with that we support there is
an element of in-country capacity
building and that supports training
design in response to specific needs of
the community or heritage professionals
in the country we do not dictate what it
is that the training is about we ask the
project to suss it out and to ensure
that the real need is addressed in
broader terms we believe that local
community involvement and local
community investment is essential for
the project's success this
successful and to be sustainable a
project cannot be seen as an issue
initiative led by outsiders rather it
has to be a partnership it has to
involve local people local experts where
whenever it is needed and whenever it is
possible we ask the project of reinforce
the local communities relationship with
the heritage and over the years this
approach has proven has been proven
successful we often see that such
approach leads to revelation of heritage
that might have been neglected or not
not seen as a value the second principle
in addition to working with local
communities is working with other sir
can you hear me the second principle is
working with others that work in the
field so we always ask the project
before we funded to establish who else
is active in the field and to make sure
that they do not duplicate they do not
make things difficult for each other but
they do partner up and they do support
each other in their important work
finally and perhaps most importantly we
require that all materials such as
digital documentation but also reports
academic publications produces arcadia
support are published online and we
absolutely require that they are open to
all and freely accessible this is this
is one of very few conditions on which
we do not budge this is particularly
important because of majority well in
terms of arcadia this is particularly
important because the majority of
projects we work with focus on digital
documentation of tangible and intangible
heritage so endangered languages and
then German script art objects
archeological sites you name it we
probably digitize it the underlying idea
is that at the very least we can secure
a record of the heritage a record that
will be preserved even if the objects
size or cultural phenomena are lost
indeed in some cases for example in case
of dying languages which can no longer
be revitalized documenting and preserve
a memory of the language is the only
thing we can do when a revitalization is
still possible digital documentation
often provides basis for the materials
that support it in case of tangible
heritage archaeological sites aquatica
objects or manuscript collections the
digital documentation helps in heritage
management but also and I'm glad that it
responds to several of the desiderata
voice today it helps potentially to
recover stolen objects that are
illegally traded and to illustrate the
types of projects we we support and I'm
very glad as quite a few of them are
represented here today we work with a
hill museum and Manuscript library this
is an organization that digitizes
manuscripts in Middle East in Africa and
in India they always work with local
churches with local mosques with local
populations they have been working in
Syria until April 2012 and they still
work in Iraq they have been working
these dominicans imissu who are now
relocated to reveal one example of
success of their success or there are
numerous examples of their success but
they have been visualizing mon scripts
in Aleppo manuscripts that have since
been lost we hope they'll be retrieved
but in worst case scenario there is a
there is a lasting record of these
manuscripts they have also digitalized a
collection in marbella monastery which
has been partially destroyed in march
this year we also partner with Oxford
endangered ecological project which is
represented in the room this is a
project that uses a combination of
satellite imagery and online on ground
documentation to monitor sites
archaeological sites in the Middle East
they started with Jordan Libya in and
Saudi Arabia now importantly they do not
only focus on destruction which results
from worth or any other violent means
there is a significant destruction going
simply because of the booster
populations partially
refugees are due to road constructions
agriculture and this is actually a
destruction that we possibly can stop
because unfortunately at this point as
several of previous speakers said we
can't do that for the destruction
undertaken by Isis we also support
British Museum's work they work with
colleagues in Egypt to catalogue and
provide digital documentation of
archaeological storage facilities the
Egypt as I don't have to even say that
Egypt has vast storage facilities that
have not been documented simply because
of the volume of the materials the idea
the underlying principle of this project
is training with trainers so the British
Museum that British Museum team is going
to train to provide on-the-job training
for the heritage professionals in Egypt
but and documenting a process first few
storages and then supervised
documentation of the following storages
until the Egyptians colleagues can
continue on their own importantly the
digital documentation allows sharing
sorry now moving off of moving on from
illustrating the types of projects we
support perhaps i'll add one more
because some some one of the previous
speakers are think the person speaking
about Molly mentioned the living
heritage we do support that as well I'm
very proud that we support a project
that our documents mundy and heritage
mandiant is a very small group that is
almost always forgotten when the plight
of people in Middle East is discussed
they are Gnostic they are not Christian
they are not Muslim they are not Jewish
and as such they are fair game to all
extremists it's a very old religion
going back to Lisa 1st century AD it's a
very very small group and this is really
last moment to document they heritage we
are very happy that the Exeter
University and the lady
versity partner with us and with the
community who reached out asking for the
heritage to be documented now
importantly the digital documentation
allows sharing and giving access to
heritage without physically removing it
from its custodians this is as we
believe a unique to for raising
awareness and for ensuring that the
world's cultural heritage can be really
recognized as such to put it bluntly if
a cultural heritage is the heritage of
the world then the world needs to be
able to access it this might not always
be possible for the actual physical
objects for very practical reasons for
sites and for phenomena but access to
digital records cannot be limited to
users from subscribing subscribing
academic institutions now I'll pause
here and i'll try to put i think that
they're going to be legitimate concerns
about the safety but let me explain we
are reasonable we do ask projects to
release photographs of objects but we do
not ask them to release objects
locations so of course there is a degree
but there is a level of information that
cannot be made public but pay walls and
barriers can only serve to frustrate and
alienate and we cannot expect people to
understand and to act to protect
cultural heritage if even the digital
record is not open to them fundamentally
making the records available to all is a
unique tool in creating and
understanding that the cultural heritage
is not only a heritage of one country or
one community but assured heritage of
all of us and outshot our shared
responsibility now I was going to stop
here but I will say one more thing and
this is not I do not suggest an online
work with Isis but I think we should
pause and think that it is very easy for
teenagers in England in Germany to
access extra miss materials to access
their calls for the destruction of
heritage it is significantly more
difficult for the same teenagers to
access scholarly articles that that that
can explain to them would this heritage
released and perhaps we could try to
begin to address it thank you
you